welcome
and um
we are very excited today uh to talk to
you about vendoring pi data for
enterprise software supply chain um my
name is zaid ma i'm presenting today
with hussein sultan
i'm currently i'm a technical program
manager united states air force um
specifically with 39 software
engineering group
um i came from a background in academics
in physics which lend itself to a lot of
data analytics and and that has fed into
the problems that we're facing today in
the air force um of we have petabyte
scale data problems of of where we're
not analyzing our data um to its maximum
efficiency and potential
so
um
over using uh thank you so much i am
hussein
as
they had mentioned i'm a pi data
consultant uh collaborating with the air
force and the zaid's team and
transforming and modernizing the
data analytics infrastructure uh as well
as the analytics processes
um i
previously come from the
world of the banking where i
institutionalize the pi data tools uh in
the in the enterprise setting in
irregular and compliant environments
i am very excited to be here today to
talk to you guys about some of the
innovation that we are doing on the
rendering pi data tools uh for
for uh high
secure environments
back to using
all right thanks hussain
um so the problem that we're facing is
we have like like i said we have
petabytes of data in in secure
environments primarily high dimensional
time series telemetry from avionics
it's not the only data type we have but
it is is our primary focus right now and
there's a lot of really
good
and powerful tools in the open source
world and and we'd like to bring those
tools and techniques to our domain
challenges um however sitting in the
middle of that is is a software supply
chain so how do we take all these these
these amazing tools and move them into
our our secure environments and so what
comes along with that air force there's
a lot of regulations that we have to
deal with um
cyber security is obviously a big
concern on how you package up and
deliver that software is is is important
um how those environments are actually
connected can create problems and we
need to do all this with minimal
operational overhead um so that it
doesn't become an unnecessary an undue
burden to actually make this a reality
but okay given that we can move it um
then once the once that one once the
open source tools are are on now next to
our domain challenges we will quickly
identify any gaps or problems that those
those tools have for our problem sets
and and we would feed those back to
community either through direct
contribution or or through engagement so
the the bottom line is that we want to
have a process to rapidly instantiate
robust data science tool sets and data
platforms in our secure environments
to meet some of our very real challenges
that we have today
so in that software supply chain
problem there's there's there's there's
there steps to this um so you have to
package and deliver the software
um then you have to scan it and make
sure that
that it's it doesn't have malware
ransomware or contain threats that could
happen downstream after we maybe we make
software and deliver to someone else now
and that adds a new problem so all those
things are concerns and then on top of
all that you then have to document
everything you've done um through
software bill materials and and
dependency checks and audits and
documentation and so on and so forth and
so um
the
in in the current condi ecosystem
there's not a good way um to to to do
that and so we have built a tool called
condo vendor to help with the with the
ska and and documentation piece of it
and i'll hand it over to hussein to demo
awesome thank you so much as zade
mentioned that we have we've created a
new tool out in the open source it is it
is available in buchanan forge
the tool is called the conda vendor and
the premise of it is that i i as
the data scientist may have a con
environment the yaml file and i want to
be able to use that in that that
environment just solve for it um
at a place where i may not have internet
access or in in in an air gap
environment
um in order to solve for that problem uh
our approach is that we start from an
environment of yaml file in this case
i'm just showing you a simple uh
environment with pandas in there
and then we go to a two-step process the
first step essentially takes that
environment
the yaml file as an input and outputs a
meta
manifest the second step takes that meta
manifest and outputs a local channel uh
that can be used for offline work so uh
what it basically means is that once you
have the local channel
to create it you can pass the dash c
flag to the kind of create and be able
to create uh your
channels from sorry your uh
environments from an offline completely
air-gapped environment
some of the features as i mentioned we
do create offline channels but we also
uh
mirror the upstream patch we put it at
the json uh so that we can have the the
correct dependencies uh and and help the
solver with that um it is the design
with a github's pattern um in mind uh
and
hence why we have a yaml file in the
middle that drives the
second step of
mirroring the channels
we also support
multiple architectures including windows
and these local channels can easily be
like mirrored to artifactory or anaconda
teams products as well
so how do we do this the first step um
i
briefly introduced earlier uh
it amounts to is that it will take the
environment
environment the yaml file and you create
a kind of log file under the hood using
that the log file we have the minimal
spec that we need to recreate that
environment downstream and we output a
lot of that information along with some
other metadata
as an example
the license types md5 or sha-256
information about those packages in this
meta manifest.yaml
once we have that meta manifest.yml
we can now
create uh but we can now use that to
actually create the local channels and
in that process we also download all of
the guitar balls and validate their
ashati v6 checksums
that were
derived from manifestation
here's a
more the detailed process flow i'm not
going to go into it
in this talk but in lieu of it i will
show you a live demo
all right so i am in a
fresh environment um
i will go ahead and and and install
kind of render
and at this point is it's just
going to download it as a connect
package from kind of forge the channel
kind of vendor is already available
there
awesome so now we already have this
package
let's look at a
example environment.yaml file
in this case we're just adding panels
but let's for
the sake of it also add matplotlib
okay
once we have the environment created
then we can
do kind of vendor and
call the meta manifest
and we can then pass the environment
file with
dash file
flag
all right
so now you will notice that it it it
automatically
defaulted to the os x64 platform uh it
has the specs correctly identified and
it also identifies the channel that it
is going to mirror
um so so at this point it is you're
going to run the kind of lock uh
kind of lock um
under the hood and create the
minimal specs and then output them in
the
meta manifest file
so let's look at the meta manifest file
really quickly
uh this is the
same structure that i showed earlier in
the powerpoint slide
but we can essentially just just like
go through it and
do an eyeball
test so here we have you know you know
all the information about our packages
you know
including the dependencies
[Music]
md5
shotiv6 as well as
the
license type and license family
information
also so we have that
um now
once we've created this
manifest file now we can we can
essentially
use that as the input to the condom in
the channels file of
the channels command
channels and we will pass the meta
manifest file with a dash m flag and
what this will do is that it will create
a mirror of this
channel that i can then use locally
and it will
in my case it is just going to
download it here so this is my complete
path to this channel
that i will be able to use
downstream to actually create this
environment again
as as the
and and the processes is
done so now we can um
go ahead and look at and and examine the
structure for our local channel
and here's how that would look like so
we have our
no arch and and os 664
channels with all updated reported.jsons
what we can do from here is
we can use this channel so let's do
connor create
uh we'll call a new end
um
so let's do matplotlib pandas matplotlib
and let's go ahead and
call this
new environment
test
and let's not create it and i'll just do
a dry run just for the sake of the demo
so we don't actually end up creating
this one
but you don't do dry run on this
sorry you cannot do it
yes and what this is uh now should do is
show us a
plan uh with all of our local files
instead of using
the
online files
so here you go
there's all of our
local main
[Music]
files here and everything is coming from
our
our
offline channel
all right
so
as you saw uh we can have uh we can
create a local the channels um and
using that
a manifest file we also have an added
benefit that we can use and and directly
integrate with a current tool called
jake by
sona type
jake allows us to check for
uh vulnerabilities or uh
and also create a software build of a
materials report based on your python
environments uh but now we are able to
extend that to
kana packages here as well uh by just
using our our
meta manifest file with something ugly
hack with the vyq tool but it it results
in a vulnerabilities
report that we can then
have a discussion around or
remediate the findings later
i will let
zade talk next about uh the
real world use case where we use condo
vendor uh for onboarding jupiter hub to
a secure environment
well thanks hussein
yeah so before i um
talk about specifically how we've been
using condo vendor um in this pipeline i
need to back up and and talk
about what iron bank is for those of you
that aren't familiar
um so iron bank is a is a trusted dod
repository of digitally signed
images
for both free and open source and and
caught software
and so in order for
a a software product to
be listed on the iron bank there's a
series of scanning and and
approvals that has to go through to get
there
and one of those steps they need a
hardening what's called a hardening
manifest so anything that you put in the
container they need to know and then
they will they will run their own checks
on that and and what conde vendor has
done for us is as we update um our
data science environments that we're
trying to ship into this secure
environments
um
it uh it pretty automatically generates
the manifest file for us uh with the
exact set of dependencies that we
actually need to ensure that that's
going to to function offline and um and
then because it's automatically
generated the the iron bank uh container
hardening team um can can more quickly
uh process that and and hopefully get
our our our new software that we need or
not knew but but the package software we
needed um
moved and approved more quickly and
that's working today so we're doing that
today as we speak which is which has
been a great benefit to us
so
um that's it
and you're more than welcome to check
this out on the link below
oh yes please please do
okay
yep so we don't do this alone this is a
collaborative effort um
currently it's uh the united states air
force we have the three and i software
software engineering group the edge
teams working in metro star and quansite
um we're also working with um working
with coiled and tight lift through aft
works through through
some super grants hopefully those
technologies will be providing value to
us in the not too distant future um as
well on the right side of the screen
um i want to highlight some of our
contributions we've made to open source
um
we've in addition to conventor which you
you saw today
we are working on a project called bit
nest which will do performant binary
packet parsing using python specifically
number
we are also looking to use intake to
have to
have a persistent metadata catalog for
for rapid querying um and
as we get that catalog to a state that's
more stable and we're happy with we'll
hopefully be open sourcing that as well
um the
i really want to also highlight the
public data sets we've made available um
so there's we've taken some nasa flights
um
and turned in their chapter 10 data
format which is on a on a public bucket
in that bucket there's both raw and
parse versions for you to take a look at
if you're interested so
please do
and with that
please reach out to us if you're
interested in talking more and thank you
very much
thank you everybody